[Música]
a
escala en parís ayuda palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 el coronavirus ha acaparado la
atención mediática apartando del primer
plano temas tan preocupantes como la
contaminación según la ms cada año
mueren en el mundo 7 millones de
personas por enfermedades provocadas por
la mala calidad del aire hoy dedicamos
este programa a hablar de esta situación
y también de las soluciones para
protegerse de la contaminación y para
ello tenemos en nuestros estudios a
marisol lópez bienvenida a marisol
muchas gracias y bueno marisol usted es
colombiana economista y es responsable
de operación y producción de la empresa
francesa
aire puro una compañía que nació en 2016
y que propone unas mascarillas unos
barbijos para protegernos del aire
contaminado
qué tecnología usan a nuestros productos
efectivamente garantizan la más alta
tecnología que se puede ofrecer hoy en
el mercado nanotecnología es decir
nuestras máscaras protegen nuestros
consumidores finales de todo tipo de
gases en polen bacterias virus y
partículas finas específicamente
partículas que están conectadas con
todos los temas de polución del aire y
es capaz de filtrar el 100% de las
nanopartículas que tanto preocupan
efectivamente en existe una medida de
referencia justamente para categorizar
las diferentes digamos tipos de
partículas que éstas que están
suspendidas en el aire o en el agua
presentes en el agua y nosotros
garantizamos 100% de filtración en
nanopartículas
de máximo 30
micrones en tamaño entonces
efectivamente partículas más pequeñas
que un virus más pequeñas que un que una
bacteria son filtradas por nuestras
máscaras que son exactamente las
partículas y cuáles son las más
peligrosas
entonces las nanopartículas aída son
partículas sólidas pequeñas partículas
sólidas que están suspendidas en el aire
presentes también en el agua y que son
categorizadas como nanopartículas
justamente por la característica de su
tamaño entonces nanopartículas son
partículas que están entre 1 y 100 en
una escala de medición de nanómetros
esos son partículas las llaman
partículas y cuáles son las más no
entonces las más nocivas para
nuestras nuestra salud y el organismo
justamente son las más pequeñas todas
aquellas partículas más pequeñas en la
medida estándar que tenemos hoy de
referencia que son las pm las pm10 y de
10 hacia abajo son las partículas más
finas que justamente en el momento de la
inhalación en el proceso de respiración
que hacemos logran entrar profundamente
en los pulmones
justamente son son partículas que pueden
generar inflamación irritación infección
y ante digamos escenarios biológicos de
personas que pueden tener ya una
sensibilidad generada con problemas
cardiovasculares problemas respiratorios
pues agudizan aún más ese riesgo para
las personas entonces realmente las
partículas más finas más pequeñas que
tienen esa posibilidad de ingreso a
nuestro sistema respiratorio
profundamente son las más nocivas y al
lado de eso también el origen de las
partículas entonces si son justamente la
naturaleza de partículas que son
incidentales generadas por ejemplo por
la combustión de carburantes y las
emisiones de centrales eléctricas
estas partículas obviamente tienen
características que pueden ser
cancerígenas en contacto con el
organismo y por supuesto esto puede
generar otro tipo de enfermedades
adicionales una pregunta que nos hacemos
a menudo es cuando anuncian picos de
contaminación
es mejor quedarse en casa salir a correr
porque claro el deporte también es muy
importante justamente para luchar contra
ciertas enfermedades
justamente creo que la razón de existir
compañías como nosotros es poder poder
salir al público y decir pese a las
condiciones que el medio ambiente podría
generar nos justamente como lo que tú
anuncia estos picos de contaminación
existen productos que nos permiten
continuar la vida de día a día
protegidos justamente para este tipo de
escenarios y características entonces
nosotros justamente buscamos
promocionar alternativas que nos
permitan continuar con la vida del día a
día pero protegidos a los distintos
niveles de contaminación de polución a
los que estamos expuestos hoy la
pandemia de coronavirus ha introducido
en nuestras vidas la mascarilla que se
ha convertido en algo que forma ya parte
de nuestras vidas
ustedes también vendieron no mascarillas
durante lo más alto de la pandemia pero
las mascarillas también contaminan es
una ecuación un poco complicada no la
que hay que hacer claro es un nuevo
residuo digamos y justamente compañías
como nosotros estamos llamados hoy más
que nunca en nuestros procesos
productivos a incluir esta logística de
reversa para garantizar que la parte
digamos
reutilizable
sea reciclada correctamente y nosotros
seamos capaces no solamente de proveer
el producto pero también de recoger en
el mercado los residuos que se generan
que es básicamente material plástico
que se puede procesar y reutilizar de
nuestro lado justamente
siendo promotores de cuidar y generar
una mejor condición en cuanto a la
calidad de aire que respiramos nuestra
máscara efectivamente tiene un elemento
que es el filtro que es lo que de
acuerdo a la frecuencia de utilización
de cada usuario tendría que estar
cambiando entre dos tres cuatro meses
pero la máscara es un producto en el que
hemos tomado muchísimo tiempo en
desarrollo para garantizar que sea un
producto de por vida es decir que no
genere justamente más residuos y más
contaminación en cuanto a elementos
entonces son máscaras que están hechas y
diseñadas en alta costura con tejidos y
productos realmente que garantizamos
como un uso
para la vida o sea que lo que se tendría
que cambiar digamos es solo el filtro
cada dos tres o cuatro meses dependiendo
del uso y es ahí donde se tendría que
introducir una cadena para ese reciclaje
y no generar más residuos bueno y
respirar aire limpio puede salir
bastante caro porque ahora vamos a
hablar del precio de estas mascarillas
la mascarilla que propone en cuesta 119
euros y el filtro 29 euros ese filtro
que se tendría que cambiar dependiendo
del uso entre uno dos tres cuatro cada
uno dos tres cuatro meses es un poco
exclusivo no este producto sabiendo
además que los más ricos son los que más
contaminan según un estudio de oxfam
internacional el 1% más rico de la
población mundial ha sido responsable de
más del doble de las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero que los cerca de
los 3100 millones de personas que
conforman el 50 por ciento más pobre es
posible democratizar las mascarillas
este tipo de más carillas
justamente a idea nuestro propósito para
el cierre de este año es tratar de
generar a nivel producción y ese es mi
mayor objetivo y mi mayor
responsabilidad en producciones en
distintos continentes justamente para
garantizar que este precio sea un precio
mucho más asequible hoy
desafortunadamente creo que todas las
industrias incluidos nosotros tenemos
que hacer frente a los altos costos y
gastos logísticos que implica justamente
importación y exportación no solamente
el producto terminado pero de toda la
cadena productiva esto hace por supuesto
que se encarezca el producto y al lado
de esto por supuesto la calidad de
materias primas que nosotros utilizamos
hacen parte también de esta
categorización de nano tecnología
justamente para garantizar la calidad de
servicio en filtración que estamos
ofreciendo entonces es un producto de
alto costo sin duda pero porque tiene
una calidad muy elevada en su desarrollo
y en sus materias primas al lado de esto
la digamos la cadena logística para
exportar al mundo entero este tipo de
productos hace que el producto sea aún
más costoso pero sin duda hace parte de
nuestros objetivos
y logré lograr tener producciones en
lugares donde justamente con volúmenes
de mayor escala logremos tener un precio
mucho más competitivo pero sobre todo
que nos permita tener más alcance a la
población hace parte de los objetivos
pensar en una vida en la que la
mascarilla es
prácticamente obligatoria para poder
respirar da un poco de miedo no o sea la
alternativa no podría ser otra que ésta
de salir tapados para no morirse es una
muy buena pregunta yo pienso que la
responsabilidad social que tenemos está
como en dos pilares sí sin duda las
grandes industrias generadoras del mayor
digamos volumen de nanopartículas que
están hoy en el aire que respiramos creo
que son ellos los llamados justamente
hacer esa contribución de cuáles son
esas estrategias que se definirán
seguramente en un corto mediano y largo
plazo pero cuáles son esas estrategias y
proyectos que van a ayudar a que esa
emisión
de todo este tipo de polución
contaminación se disminuyan pero al lado
de eso creo que también compañías como
nosotros estamos llamados a encontrar
soluciones temporales y eventualmente
definitivas ojalá que no sean
definitivas pero al menos las temporales
mientras el otro pilar digamos de las
grandes industrias logra compensar un
poco como nosotros y logramos ofrecer al
mercado soluciones que nos permitan
sentir esa tranquilidad ese cuidado ese
respaldo y no cambiar la vida y el
estilo de vida que quizá hoy tenemos
aquí y que creo que todos nosotros
quisiéramos mantener cuál es el
diagnóstico que hacen de la calidad del
aire en las grandes ciudades donde hay
mucho tráfico por ejemplo entonces
nosotros justamente hemos hecho un muy
buen desarrollo en nuestra plataforma
que es justamente una aplicación
completamente gratuita para todos
nuestros utilizadores de producto es una
plataforma que está conta que está
conectada con distintas entidades
nacionales locales internacionales que
nos permiten tener certitud y sobre todo
fiabilidad
de los tintos picos de polución que se
generan
724 en las distintas ciudades donde
están nuestros consumidores entonces son
puntos de referencia realmente
importantes y confiables y que respaldan
y acompañan a un consumidor de una
máscara como la nuestra justamente para
saber cuál es la vida útil de su filtro
y sobre todo cuál ha sido la exposición
que ha tenido su sistema respiratorio
y cuál ha sido entonces su porcentaje de
protección y cómo en su día a día la
persona va a tener digamos una mayor
información y visibilidad y control de
cuáles son los picos que tiene que
evitar cuáles son las zonas que quizá
tiene que evitar también o especialmente
dónde es cuando más tiene que estar
protegido con su máscara pero sin duda
personas que están expuestas
un número importante de horas al día a
este nivel de polución sin duda son
personas que necesitan protegerse con
una máscara que garantice ese nivel de
filtración bueno en cuántas mascarillas
han han vendido y dónde bueno hemos
tenido la suerte de tener un muy muy
buen una muy buena respuesta del mercado
a la fecha hemos vendido ya 60 mil
máscaras básicamente el mercado francés
es sin duda pues uno de nuestros
principales mercados europa digamos en
un segundo alcance también nuestra
plataforma de venta online que es
nuestro mayor canal de distribución hoy
está abierto para américa es decir eeuu
sudamérica asia y sin duda claro los
países y sobre todo las grandes
capitales donde el efecto de polución
contaminación es muy elevado pues es
donde tenemos una mayor respuesta del
mercado pues marisol lópez muchísimas
gracias ustedes recordemos el
responsable de operación y producción de
la empresa francesa
yo le agradecemos por esta entrevista
ayudan muchas gracias a ustedes y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir internet en rf y mundo.com
y en france 24 punto com hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]